l'attendu souvent le double oui des fois
on l'attend et même elle ne passe pas
métro j'aime ça mais ce que j'aime pas
c'est les prolongements de métro d arrêt
de service wind service de bus rapide
dans la gueule ça c'est très intéressant
je trouve qu'il ya dans notre monde nos
mamans d'un match où vous avez été
extrêmement nombreux à nous écrire nous
envoyer vos questions parce que le
transport en commun
c'est un sujet qui vous préoccupe parce
que vous le prenez souvent matin et soir
nous avons donc nous l'avions invité sur
ce plateau il ya quelques semaines
mais l'actualité avait fait que
l'entrevue avait été très courte
philippe schnobb je lui avais dit en
direct
je voudrais inviter pour prendre le
temps de répondre aux questions mais ça
y est philippe schnobb bonsoir soit
merci d'être là
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de questions
d'ailleurs on va vous remettre toutes
les questions à la fin de l'émission
vous pourrez voyager et répondre aux
s'il est habituellement très bien
peuvent se la voir l'onl en cette
semaine de travail
il y en a beaucoup les thèmes les plus
populaires qui sont revenus
les pannes la fréquence qui est pas
suffisante et les projets futurs les
gens se demandent est-ce qu'on va
améliorer telle voie réservée est ce que
tel tracy pour est améliorée un pointe
aux trembles je ne suis pas desservie
alors on va y aller assez rapidement
avec les questions du public et je
voulais dit à la maison si vous voulez
appeler on vous donnera les numéros de
téléphone en super on prendre quelques
appels ou si à la fin pira je vais
présenter des questions en rafale
alors d'abord une un nouveau une
nouvelle donne et philippe schnobb sur
l'achalandage
ceci tout nouveau ça vient de sortir en
vous avez 3 4% d'augmentation 2018
c'était 5% donc l'augmentation est plus
faible
l'année qui vient de se terminer à ce
que ça vous déçoit comment tu tout pas
du tout l'important c'est là c'est la
tendance la tendance à lille la même
depuis plusieurs années là depuis 2014
et 12% de croissance dans le métro 12 %
c'est énorme c'est énorme c'est beaucoup
plus de gens ça crée même à certains
moments des difficultés on dit que la
ligne orange peut être engorgé à
certains moments c'est vrai c'est la
conséquence de
une bonne nouvelle la croissance de
l'achalandage mais ça vient avec un
certain nombre de petits ennuis là qu'il
faut savoir avec lesquels il faut savoir
vivre et est justement parents de petits
ennuis les gens nous ont beaucoup écrit
sur les fameuses panne en trombe sur la
ligne orange et là on a les chiffres que
nous vous nous avez donné de l'est
m'expliquer ça il ya eu au moins deux
pannes dites vous en 2010 9 par rapport
à 2018 on va voir le tableau 964 panne
une diminution de 10% par rapport à 2010
8 où il y avait eu plus de 1000 ça c'est
les plats ne s'est pas celui là
les pannes donc 964 diminution et par
les passants les gens par cette
impression à ça c'est vrai la perception
tellement loin de la réalité
d'abord nous on appelle ça des arrêts de
service je voudrais pourquoi parce
qu'une panne il ya des pannes
il ya des endroits il y en a eu cette
semaine douce et le matériel roulant
c'est le train qui a des problèmes aux
systèmes électriques sont en panne mais
comme on disait
de plus en plus il ya une grande partie
des arts et de services qui sont au
comportement de certains clients
puissent aussi en a eu beaucoup cette
semaine pendant dix ans depuis le début
de l'année on est très fiers de voir
qu'on a une réduction du nombre d'arrêts
de service en 2018 il y avait une
réduction des rides service aussi en
2017 et
et pas simplement en chiffres absolus il
ya aussi une diminution un nombre
d'heures perdues
donc ça veut dire que si un arrêt de
service ont été capables de remettre le
service en fonction plus rapide quoi
c'est du tout ça il y en a quand même y
en a quand même il y en a quand même il
est là je vais vous amener une autre
statistique qui était importante pour
nous au conseil d'administration parce
qu'il faut qu'on puisse voir comment ça
se passe ailleurs
si on regarde sa part millions de
kilomètres parcourus c'est le critère
international on a deep and deep and 10
arrêt de service par millions de
kilomètres parcourus la moyenne
internationale pour des métros de notre
grosse heure ses 23 ans aux siens en
temps avec les autres on a une bonne
performance le succès change rien quant
à un arrêt de service de savoir qu'il ya
de plus ailleurs qu'elle nous comme
conseil si on veut voir si la direction
fait du bon travail il faut qu'on soit
capable de voir ce qui se passe ailleurs
quelles sont les raisons pour lesquelles
ça baise faut le comprendre
on a des nouveaux trains nous nouveaux
trains ils sont extrêmement performants
ils ont une performance et une fiabilité
beaucoup plus grandes que les vieux
trains évidemment est encore beaucoup
plus grande que ce qui était attendu
alors c'est tout à fait normal et ça va
s'améliorer parce qu'on va voir d'autres
traduit en 2000 et dans tous les détails
ont fait une courte pause mesdames et
messieurs on revient avec vos questions
il y en a une rafale ça va aller assez
rapidement en trois minutes
on part tout ça je vous rappelle que
vous pouvez nous appeler aux six ou 5 1
4 5 9 000 7 9 0 pardon 000 habitants
[Musique]
si xavier phillips in home devant vous
président la stm qu'est ce que vous lui
demanderez d'améliorer pour le métro
parce que y'a tout dit à des retards
trop souvent est plutôt une panne
ça revient ça revient l'histoire des
panneaux reçu des centaines de courriels
donc vous dites il y en a eu un peu
moins mais manifestement même si on se
compare on se console
c'en est trop pour les gens il ya michel
et roncq à michel biron qui nous écrit
comment comptez-vous résoudre le
problème de la ligne orange constamment
pas d'abord je veux juste comme je les
dis constamment à prendre le métro roule
sans problème 99% du temps je les dis
merci j'en parle plus mais comment on
fait ça c'est important parce qu'il faut
trouver des solutions qui en a trop qui
en est - il y en a il faut savoir
pourquoi il y en a et comment régler ça
je les dis de matériel roulant les
nouveaux trains sont plus performants on
a réglé ça on avait des problèmes de
portes
on a calé un peu depuis le début de
l'année on essaie de régler ça sur les
vieilles voitures
on veut installer des portes palières
pour réduire le nombre d'incidents qui
sont liées à de vrais des comportements
des gens qui échappent des choses qui
descendent sur la voie par les chercher
des intrusions grenelle lors pas liens
qu'ils ne portent pas dire ça c'est des
portes sur le quai qui fait en sorte que
vous avez pas accès aux trois là où tu
es pas accès aux voies il faut pas
descendre dans dom ça éviterait ça
éviterait les portes
ça éviterait les tentatives de suicides
aussi en a 21 mai 20 à 25 par année qui
c'est malheureux mais avec des portes
palières de masse avis c'est un vague
projet ou sa vrai projet naquit qui ont
convaincu qu'on va faire un projet
pilote dans le cadre du prolongement de
la ligne bleue et le projet là un moyen
terme c'est de pouvoir le faire sur une
bonne partie de la ligne orange
jusqu'à bonaventure ce mémoire est bonne
donc ça c'est quelque chose qu'il n'y
ait pas de l'année prochaine mais qui va
faire partie de notre prochain plan
stratégique c'est important ça va aider
à réduire le nombre d'incidents
il faut travailler là dessus il faut
travailler sur notre matériel roulant et
aussi sur le comportement des clients
parce que il ya la moitié des arts et de
services sont dus au comportement de
certains clients
et c'est pas on le répète peas et déjà
molle mais il faut qu'on sache il faut
que tout le monde fasse sa part c'était
le travail qu'on a affaire en somme on a
fait des campagnes dans le métro ça
donne des résultats mais pas encore
assez claude leboeuf qui vous demande
pour désengorger la ligne orange plus de
voies réservées dans l' axe nord sud
c'est ce qu'on a fait avec la 4,45
papineau qui est un grand succès l'idée
c'est de développer des lignes de bus la
97 qui fait ça aussi pour permettre aux
gens de venir travailler au centre-ville
sans avoir à prendre le métro
et ça fonctionne les gens du plateau les
gens de rosemont prennent la 4 45e
l'achalandage a doublé et on l'a mis en
service en septembre on va augmenter le
service en marque ce conte et sardine
est ce qu'on attend l'idée c'est de
permettre aux gens d'avoir une autre
option puis de faire le déplacement sans
avoir à transiter par de métro et ça
fonctionne ça donne des bons résultats
et on va en faire d'autres on va
continuer à développer ces axes la très
bien on savent au téléphone alors denis
robert monsieur robert bonsoir bonsoir
vous êtes dans quel coin me robert
lahaye et les vallées
vous avez tout à fait raison d'une
excellente question qu'on voulait poser
plus tard on impose tout de suite ce
chenal
quand on se compare là dessus on se
désole totalement quelqu'un qui veut
prendre le métro à longueuil ne peut pas
fonctionner avec une carte puce même
s'il circule à mon là tout le reste la
journée ce défaut racheter un autre
billet acheté un autre billet alors à
quand une harmonisation
ouais mais là je peux pas vous donner
leur a donné la réponse plate la ccl la
responsabilité de l'autorité régionale
des transports metropolit et qui a été
créée la rtm qui as a comme mandat de
réduire le nombre de titres de
simplifier la tarification est tous là
et ce thème a pas de juridiction sur les
tarifs à longueuil
valou il comprendrait et donc c'est la
responsabilité de l'autorité ils sont en
train de travailler là-dessus qui
devrait arriver avec des solutions d'ici
au cours de 2010 est ce qu'on nous a dit
ouais c'est effectivement la réponse
plate
vous êtes un joueur important dans la
rtm vous êtes le gros joueur de la
région on est lui toujours en dépression
parce que ça s'en vient vent avant dix
ans de notre point de vue il faut que ça
se fasse on est tout à fait d'accord il
faut régler cette question là des enjeux
des gens qui doivent racheter bien
longueuil laval c'est remonte à des
missions politiques dieu disant tout ça
quand le métro de laval au vert mais il
faut régler ces enjeux l'homme il faut
surtout simplifier les tarifs la grille
tarifaire et on contribue aux différents
groupes qui est dessus du sol mais c'est
vraiment la responsabilité de la rtm de
faire de trouver des conclusions
là-dessus j'aimerais vous en dire plus
mais c'est long on en est dans les
discussions moi je participe pas
directement ces discussions-là l'eau au
moulin forme saas et bonnardel a mené
des transports à qu'il faut poser la
question ce qui va mettre plus de
pression sur la rtm pour que ça se fasse
d'ici un an ou deux ça devrait se faire
plus rapidement que seuls ses sens et
serait en 2020 oui bon on commençait à
se faire en 2002 merci courriel monsieur
nicolas joel obi chaque nouvelle voie
réservée est une artère de moins pour
les cyclistes
plusieurs villes dans le monde
permettent le partage des voies
réservées entre le vélo pourquoi pas ici
je sais que vous faites du vélo en ville
ce choc
alors est ce assez revenue assez souvent
cette question oui on nous en parle
beaucoup c'est sûr que quand on déploie
des voies réservées et que la
conséquence c'est qu'on ne peut pas
rouler en vélo dans les voies réservées
ça crée évidemment des difficultés parce
que nos intentions sont pas d'empêcher
les gens de rouler à vélo dans l'eau
formé comité quand on s'appelle le
comité bus vélo il ya des gens de la
ville il ya des gens de vélo québec et
légendes à palissy à des gens de la
société d'assurance automobile
on va consulter les cyclistes on va
consulter aussi nos chauffeurs de bus
pour voir comment peut il y allait d'un
dans quel contexte dans quel encadrement
on peut rendre sécuritaire parce que la
préoccupation de la stm et de ses
chauffeurs ccc la sécurité des cyclistes
parce que c'est quand on est en vélo on
pense que tout le monde nous voit et
tout mais le chauffeur de bus lui sont
ses angles morts il y en a quand même
pas mal et les chauffeurs veulent
simplement s'assurer que tout le monde
roule en sécurité alors on est en train
de travailler là-dessus on devrait
arriver à une conclusion l'appui des
recommandations d'ici avant idéalement
avant le début de la saison de v
chic maintenant la saison de vélo ces
douze mois avant le début de la vague
printemps avant la fin la fin du
printemps très bien un appel de claude
boulanger du centre-ville de montréal
monsieur boulanger vous écoles oui la
question et pour les personnes à faible
revenu et les personnes âgées on l'avait
promis dès des ray ban le bea avait
promis la gratuité pour les personnes
âgées way monsieur bélanger me boulanger
votre question elle et elle revient
souvent vous avez raison et encore là la
stm n'a plus juridiction sur les tarifs
mais on contribue quand même à la
réflexion n'est ce pas là un système qui
décide que les augmentations de tarifs
maintenant on est on conseille on
suggère et la cmm est en train d'étudier
la question de la tarification sociale
parce qu'il faut voir là dedans
quel est l'objectif qu'on cherche c'est
la même
c'est la communauté métropolitaine jeu
voir poser la question de ce mélange est
plus directement de ce chemin oui votre
patronne
oui je ne vous oublie pas monsieur
boulange votre patronne la mairesse de
montréal a promis aux montréalais de
rendre le transport en commun à montréal
gratuit pour les personnes âgées ça va
tu arrives et oui ou non c'est en train
de se discuter il faut voir les impacts
faut voir combien ça coûte
et c'est ce que la communauté
métropolitaine est en train de faire
avec la rtm aussi parce qu'encore là les
revenus vient de la rta mal à sion
décide de donner de gratuité ça veut
dire qu'il faut trouver les montants qui
viennent la lada tarification des aînés
folie trouver ailleurs ce qu'ils sont en
train de calculer tout ça il faut
regarder dans cette réflexion là qui on
veut aider
est ce que c'est c'est l'ensemble des
rennais qui ont besoin de ce soutien là
est ce qu'on peut y aller différemment
il faut regarder toutes ses questions à
qui on veut aider précisément plutôt d'y
aller at love très bien on fait le corps
te pose après la pause et ce thème
pourrait elle a augmenté le nombre de
métro à l'heure de pointe dans trois
minutes rester là
[Musique]
la pâte et a demandé le nombre de
véhicules aux heures de pointe d'une
part et la fréquence en général ces
gratte on pense des deux vaisseaux
damian puis qui passent pas toujours aux
dernières se fait souvent l'on attende
ça répondait au monsieur qui vient dire
ça c'est revenu beaucoup aussi
l'exactitude l'heure le bidule qui se
posent à nous dire à quelle heure
l'autobus arrive souvent ça ne
fonctionne pas on en a eu dans
l'implantation avec ibus le ce qui nous
permet de savoir le temps réel ça
fonctionne généralement mais ça peut
arriver que ça flanche et
mais je dois dire que les enjeux de
ponctualité ils sont réels les gens
raison de dire que le bus est en retard
il ya eu différents facteurs en 2019
à un moment donné on a manqué d'autobus
succès n'a cédé que c'est ce qui
explique sam autres matches tous les
chantiers en ville ça fait en sorte que
dans certains cas des taux dix peut pas
aller plus vite que lui mais ce qui vous
semble vous nous avez donné des chiffres
seront d'autant plus qu'on veut voir le
tableau la flotte totale 1882 service
normal 14
1425 parce qu'il y en a bien sûr sont au
garage en décembre cbc à 1300 on s'en
souvient de la crise février ses revenus
à 1425 c'est sûr c'est un moteur 1425
savary d'une journée à l'autre mais en
général sa joie ont atteint aujourd'hui
on avait le 1425 on en avait même un peu
plus ce qui permettait d'avoir une marge
de manoeuvre il essaie d'avoir aussi une
marge de manoeuvre est donc les 1425
pouvait rouler ce matin donc on a réussi
à regagner du terrain de ce côté là le
cerveau bien mais c'est encore fragile
parce que vous nous donner ces dates là
mais le 30 mars quand le tunnel du mont
royal va fermer là on en a besoin de
1471 il faut qu'on continue à travailler
pour avoir la marge de manoeuvre
nécessaire
ce sont nos objectifs le 30 mars 1471 et
ça va être encore plus élevé à septembre
parce que l'on veut augmenter le service
de 5% avec les nouveaux bus qu'on soit 2
les 300 bus il faut que ça commence à
paraître pour les clients ça va
commencer en septembre
oui et ce manque d'autobus fait en sorte
pour le dit tout à l'heure un peu que
les gens c'est la classe sardines
monsieur mathieu blanchette qui écrit le
nouveau 4 4 5 ans on a parlé tout à
l'heure express papineau vous dites ça
marche
oui ça marche tellement bien est en
surcharge nous sommes compacts et dit-il
les uns sur les autres
nous sommes retournés à notre voiture ça
c'est moins drôle
à cause des conditions exécrables
pourquoi ne pas s'ajuster à demain c'est
ce qu'on va faire le plus vite possible
au monde au mois de mars
c'est ce qu'on sait ce qui est prévu il
est déjà calculé qu'on va augmenter
servi de la 4,45 en mars pourquoi pas
avant c'est encore l'est une question de
disponibilité de véhicules s'élèverait
photo je le sais je la prend 4,45 aussi
de temps en temps pour aller voir
comment ça fonctionne que je les prends
matin avec le nez à la fenêtre mais
aussi non
et je sais ce que c'est d'autres fois je
m'installe sur le trottoir je les
regarde pas assez pour leur gardien du
monde dedans je le sais qu on a ce
problème là mais et nous experts le font
aussi en regardant les statistiques
quotidiennes et ils savent qu'il faut
s'ajuster que ça on va le faire le plus
vite possible parce que quand on aura
plus de bus ça fait partie de l'équation
bon alors plus de bus un appel d'olivier
benoît de montréal monsieur benoit vous
écoutent oui bonsoir monsieur roybon
soirée chez je crois je voudrais
demander mais qu'est ce qu'ils n'ont
nous qui habitons à montréal-nord et qui
confronte on a tous les jours des
problèmes sur la bnf salon prend
quasiment une héroïne loupe apple du
métro pie-ix jusqu'à 1 ribot à la merci
merci pour votre question c'est parce
que benoît mais vous savez il ya des
travaux majeurs sur pie-ix parce qu'on
est en train de construire un serbe et
c'est la raison pour laquelle il ya des
perturbations parce que les bus doit
faire des détours mais quand on aura
complété la serbie en 2022 vous allez
avoir des autobus brescou minutes pour
descendre au centre-ville puis rentrez
chez vous le soir la situation va être
très très très différentes
il faut rêver un peu leur faut regarder
un peu de vent mais en attendant
évidemment parce qu'il ya des travaux ça
peut avoir des impacts et à l'intérieur
de tout ça en vaut aussi améliorer le
service dans des secteurs comme montréal
nord parce que c'est des secteurs qui en
ont besoin on le sait la même chose pour
rivière des prairies pointe aux trembles
quand on voit expliquer ce qu'on va
faire avec les 300 bus il ya une portion
de ceux là qui vont aller pour et de les
servir des secteurs qui en ont grand
besoin
oui parce que pointe aux trembles on a
reçu beaucoup de courriels là dessus les
gens disent on est pas desservir ça
fonctionne pas bien dire quand même dû
servir d'appoint des grands il y en a
peut-être passé c'est ça qu'on est
oublier disent ils c'est là dessus qu'on
travaille on les a rassuré ce nom ils
ont rencontré récemment je suis à la
l'arrondissement pointe-aux-trembles ont
leur expliquer ce qu'on avait en tête
on va augmenter des choses ont offert
des interventions condé d'un poids ou
même en 2020 pour pouvoir la desserte de
scooter marie france jutras qui vous
demandent serait-il possible de
rallonger les heures de métro sur tous
les vendredis et samedis soirs on entend
souvent celle là oui la réponse c'est
non parce que la nuit dans le métro on
avait amené les médias dans le métro les
divers
dernier il ya des centaines de chantiers
dans le métro il ya des centaines de
personnes qui travaillent la semaine et
la fin de semaine aussi la fin de
semaine ont fait l'entretien des voies
donc si on faisait pas ça on aurait plus
de discuter le jour parce qu'ils se sont
fait pas un entretien et on voit des
problèmes de le métro a besoin d'être
fermée la nuit le métro est 20 40 ans ça
changera change repos parce qu'il va
toujours falloir faire de l'entretien
peut être là dans 40 à peut-être qu'on
sera fini le cycle mais encore donc
quand on va voir fini on va devoir
recommencer en effet les métros ils le
font c'est des métros il ya plusieurs
voies plusieurs lignes parallèles donc
là c'est possible de faire à londres à
paris à berlin ont fermé de linz pas
grave il y en a une autre à côté qui
vous amène au même endroit mais à
montréal on peut pas faire ce qu'on
appelle du guillaume rajotte de verdun
monsieur rage at on vous écoute votre
question à philippe chenal
d'augmentation pour les cartes opus et
en 2009 on a eu quand même énorme
occasion pourquoi je me suis pas
monsieur rajotte d'avoir dit ce qui
aurait pas d'augmentation parce que de
toute façon depuis 2007 c'est plus la
responsabilité de la stm de décider quel
sera le but l'augmentation des cartes
ans je serais étonné d'avoir dit qu'il
n'aurait pas passé comme on se parlait
du sisp une décision qui nous revient il
y à des augmentations
il y en a une qui va être prévu aussi en
juillet en effet en juillet maintenant
des augmentations qui te qu'au début de
l'année et c'est encore là c'est la
seule l'autorité régionale des
transports qui prend les décisions
le tout routier régional des transports
on va les inviter oui c'est un carnet
vous couriez les invités bon dieu tout
va se décider là mais c'est la réalité
parce qu'ils ont des responsables
allaient paris pour un allongement de
métro va prendre de la même chose
stéphane cascio nous vous écris vous
demande mon quart des buts à 6 heures
quand on dit aux gens prenaient le
transport en commun des laissez votre
voiture
voici un bel exemple mon corps débute à
6 heures et le seul autobus qui sera à
mon travail et le 209 dont le premier
paraît 6e rue et au terminus dorval
peut-on avoir des départs plus tôt pour
accommoder les travailleurs qui n'ont
pas de tous les 209 le jeune j'avoue mon
écurie je passais ou est ce que ca
c'est dans l'ouest de l'île c'est ce que
vous voyez quand vous allez à l'aéroport
il ya un terminus de bus a raconté
alors ça c'est une question assez points
au dessus je peux produire ce qu'on
ferait pendant deux ans mais ce que je
peux vous dire paraître parieurs des
fois on a des demandes comme ça on est
quelqu'un me disait quand je prends la
144e métro sherbrooke pour arriver à
l'hôtel du stade et en prix de l'hôtel
dieu
j'arrive toujours cinq minutes en retard
parce que le bus part à telle heure des
supporters dix minutes plus tôt
j'arriverai à l'heure où de plus en
considération ça change rien on a juste
changé l'heure de départ du bus pour n'a
pu dans un cas comme ça son courriel
voit on verra ce qui est possible de
faire mais il ya des surtout en début de
camp début de journée et peut-être moyen
de faire des choses mais on en a déjà
fait des choses semblent une navette de
la cmq ira le chercher mais se cassent
no mercy vous avez vous des nouvelles
stm un appel de jean marc lavigne de
pierrefonds monsieur la veille on vous
écoute de montagne doit se terminer le
1er avril tout le monde le sait c'est
terminé 1er janvier beaucoup d'usagers
l'art est servi moi je questionne sur
tous ceux qui parents vers l'ouest de
l'île il ya beaucoup de monde près de la
station de métro côte vertu de convier
que servi de nombre d'autobus aux heures
de pointe le matin et le soir à la
station métro côte vertu à l'ouest de
l'île et il y aura des services de
navettes qui vont être ajoutés dans ce
secteur là je peux pas vous dire combien
là mais si j'allais sur notre site web
vous allez le voir il y aura évidemment
le service régulier que vous fait
prendre quand vous prenez les express
qui vous amène à côte vertu
mais il y aura aussi des navettes
spéciales qu'on va offrir le service de
navettes même avec des bus qu'on appelle
koshla début ce qui roule à l'extérieur
des
des cartes des secteurs urbains mais
c'est prévu y aura des mesures qui ont
été prises a spécifiquement pour les
gens de l'ouest de l'île comme ça en
plus du service qu'on offre régulière
qu'on va offrir les services réguliers
on va on doit faire une pause mais juste
avant merci merci monsieur pour votre
question je vous disais que pointe aux
trembles on avait reçus beaucoup ça m'a
frappé de courriels daniel gingras vous
demande acker meilleur service à pointe
aux trembles autobus 410 430 les autobus
ne sont pas assez fréquent 50 minutes
debout c'est l'on dit daniel gingras
il ya des coups et encore il ya des
zones d'ombré on peut tout à fait comme
jeudi particulièrement allons nous
rencontrer l'arrondissement récemment on
s'est engagé à faire des choses
rapidement 2020 pour pouvoir dès
l'automne de faire des changements donc
on est à l'écouté aussi qu'il ya des
problèmes à certains endroits de fonds
volés prioriser après la pause on va
parler d'avenir justement le soutenable
et projets d'avenir qu'est ce qui est
dans le sac qu'est ce qui ne l'est pas
qu'est ce qui relève de la rtm on va
encore parler d'eux et du reste on vient
de la pesée messieurs dans trois minutes
a tous eu
lundi 3 février station de métro de
montréal les gens font la ligne comme
dans les années 70 pour aller recharger
leur carte opus est d'ailleurs martin
laval et vous demandent à ce propos la
peut-on envisager de se servir de notre
téléphone ou d'un service de recherche
en ligne pour acheter nos titres de
transport
monsieur china jeu tout à fait d'accord
on est au moyen âge je suis d'accord
avec vous est encore passé la rtm non ce
qui à ses responsabilités la lame et moi
tout à fait d'accord avec vous il faut
qu'on aille le plus vite possible les
moyens de recharger sa carte sans avoir
à faire le fil d'avoir un compte client
qui nous permet de renouveler la carte
automatiquement à tous les mois je suis
tout à fait d'accord avec ça et c'est la
rtm que la responsabilité c'est tout qui
travaille là dessus actuellement la
ville de montréal a gagné le défi des
villes intelligentes il ya deux ans avec
justement ce projet-là créé cet univers
loeb numérique vous pouvez recharger les
cartes
tout le monde travaille pour que ça se
fasse le plus vite possible et si je
suis pas du genre à verser près moi je
veux vous dire le corps il est tous
d'accord on est un contractuel on est un
repas de compte on est contre le on a un
contrat avec la rtm la rtm en des
juridictions des responsabilités je suis
l'une de celles là c'est la bienne s'est
cru une filière terre moi je peux vous
dire que tout à fait d'accord il faut
qu'on règle ça le plus rapidement
possible au téléphone reja castonguay
bonsoir monsieur castonguay vous allez
bien poser votre question fait les
vidanges passer sur la ligne orange a
speech est alors pour désengorger les
ignares pourquoi ne pas compléter la
mi-mars à ge avec côte-vertu côte-vertu
mme amara sy fait monsieur castonguay
d'abord je vais vous dire c'est aussi le
gouvernement du québec qui réfléchit à
ces choses-là pas ses gouvernants qui
paye 100 % faut faire des études faut
voir si la meilleure façon de
désengorger la ligne orange et de
l'afrique du faire faire une boucle ça
peut peut-être avoir l'effet contraire
c'est pour ça qu'il faut aussi envisager
ce probablement davantage ce qui est
proposé c'est à dire une ligne
transversale
ce qu'on appelle la ligne
vous qui va réussir à dégager la ligne
orange pour éviter que les gens la
prennent carrément et cette ligue là il
faut qu'on travaille là-dessus parce que
c'est un projet ou pas ce que je veux
c'est un projet qui était à l'ordre du
jour actuellement s'accroche à l'étudier
concrètement la chose qui est là
peut-être le plus concrètes à court
moyen terme ses prolongements au moins
jusqu'à bois francs pour faire le lien
avec le renne bon ligne bleue ça s'est
réglé ligne rose les roses est aussi à
l'étude faut voir quel est le meilleur
mode faut voir quel est le meilleur
contexte le meilleur tracé il ya des
gens qui travaillent là dessus et
beaucoup de gens nous ont écrit pour
quoi on ne relie pas la ligne bleue la
future instance ont pas joué avec la
verte je pourrais vous dire il ya des
gens qu'ils proposent mais actuellement
le projet de ligne bleue qui est sur la
table ne tient pas compte de ça est ce
qu'on le fera un jour peut-être mais je
peux actuellement on peut pas modifier
le projet de ligne bleue tels qu'on les
tue actuellement la passe qui aurait
repartir à zéro et on veut vraiment pas
faire ça donc il ya ceux ci ça a lieu
c'est quand aline rose
ah ben là je peux pas parler
d'échéancier je faisais que la ligne
bleue c'est peu avant 2026 comprenons
penser à l'inauguration note l'allégro
ça irait dans les sims ont commencé à la
préparer aujourd'hui faut calculer au
moins 7 ans dans un projet comme celui
là entre le début entre le moment où on
décide de le faire et le moment
l'inaugurent alors danser ce serait dans
ses horizons là est ce qu'on n'a pas
pris un retard incroyable justement dans
ces projets nos chances qu'on les a fait
une chanson désert 20 ans une chose
qu'on le fait de mettre ou ya 50 ans
d'abord parce que ce sont aujourd'hui on
n'aurait pas les moyens de faire ça
est-ce qu'on a pris du retard on a quand
même prolonger le métro à différents
moments est-ce qu'on aurait dû le faire
de façon plus plus intense peut-être les
gouvernements on crie d'être une
banlieue très de mascouche par exemple
le rem janvier ça va changer la vie
aussi le renne rechange et la ville
quelques questions rafale rapidement
mais d'abord pour les titres de
transport commun pour la grande région
m'avait dit certaines s'en occuperont
augmenter la fréquence du 250 sur rené
lévesque pour faciliter l'accès au chum
ça que tu ça fait partie des
propositions le jeu reprend sa note mais
on va regarder ce qui est passé en
egypte ne permettent aux vélos sur ce
j'ai dit au comité bus vélo organisée
par le tout multiplié agrandir les
stationnements incitatifs c'est la rt
kaka de la rtm qui doit qui doit être en
route vers le plateau ça se peut pas
écorner virus avez vous un plan
bon les gens nous poser la question à
côté il ya eu des communications qui ont
été faites auprès des employés parce
qu'il y avait une inquiétude auprès des
employés mais sinon c'est les règles
d'usagé qui sont mentionnés là il faut
beaucoup de monde la responsabilité de
sa propre religion
mais en suisse au néanmoins on attend un
dernier téléphone ce beau lui on vous
écoute
oui j'aime beaucoup ça monsieur beaulieu
il faut le boulevard pie-ix avec les
services ça sera ça là il y aura une
grande portion du boulevard pie-ix qui
va être réservé pour donner aux élèves 2
à l'aller retour la voie réservée sur
papineau convient de tirer c'est une
voie réservée aux autobus et aussi donc
oui ça se fait est ce que
l'environnement de montréal est propre
et ça sent aussi à la largeur des rues
danton de tenir compte mais on va le
fond le cat on le fait quand un serbe et
c'est ça c'est du bus en site propre et
on va bientôt arriver qu'une proposition
de développement de mesures pour les bus
qui vont tenir compte aussi de cette
logique le ferai bien petite dernière
pour la route à quand la fin des travaux
à berry bientôt ses polars tmc nous
alors je peux vous dire ça s'en vient
bientôt le même jeu passé cet après midi
il y avait quelqu'un qui est en train de
faire du plateau en train d'installer
les les parmi les les revêtements sur le
mur alors ça s'en vient et ça a été long
mais c'est il fallait le faire très bien
monsieur je nomme je vous remets des
centaines et des centaines et xo
regarder leurs émissions
il s'est engagé mais ce temps plutôt à
vous répondre alors on n'a pas eu le
temps de prendre toutes les questions
mais je pense qu'on a découvert quand
même largement moi je vous invite aussi
à venir passer une journée au centre de
contrôle avec un journaliste
une journée que ça dure 20 heures il
faudrait que sont en forme pour voir
quand vous parlez d arrêt de service et
dépendent que vous puissiez voir ce qui
se passe moi je reçois niro de vie tous
les jours on voit des gens très bien
alors accepté l'invitation acceptant
merci lévitation français épisodiquement
c'est un sujet qui passionne avec raison
les gens on veut gagner plus il faut se
donner les moyens
puis la rtm cette prochaine invitée en
met un visage là dessus
[Musique]